hi there today we're looking at
synthesizer rethinking self attention in
transformer models by etai Dhara bari
donald Metzler Shangguan Jie Zhao and
chair Cheng these people are of Google
research and on a high level they're
trying to replace the self attention
mechanism which is currently a dot
product mechanism in a transformer by a
sort of a learned a learned attention
mechanism therefore eliminating this
expensive dot product and they test the
model and conclude that it sometimes
works a bit so the results are sort of
inconclusive but that's the paper on a
high level and it's it's fairly cool to
go through and as always if you like
content like this consider subscribing
and sharing it out alright so they say
the dot product self attention is known
to be central and indispensable to state
of the art transformer models so if you
don't know what a transformer is it's
best I made a video on the attention is
all you need paper and that explains
what a transformer is and what an
attention mechanism is in detail but
they are right of course the attention
mechanism that is via the dot product of
queries and keys is pretty much what
makes transformers transformers and they
here ask is it really required which is
a bold question in light of that right
they say they they investigate whether
or not you really need this and they say
we expend extensive experiments we find
that first random alignment matrices
surprisingly perform quite competitively
and to learning attention weights from
token token that means query key
interactions which is this dot product
interaction is not that important after
all okay they proposed this new model
called synthesizer a model that learns
synthetic attention weights without
token token interactions our
experimental results show that
synthesizer is compared
if against even electrons former models
across a range of tasks okay so let's
dive in so what is what is different
here they're basically saying look in
each in each each transformer layer
boils down to something like this where
you have an input sequence X right here
and you want to get an output sequence Y
and in order to do that you need some
sort of this thing which is the
attention matrix multiplied by this
thing which are called the values and
we'll explore that a bit deeper over
here
so in these transformers it's always
kind of helpful to visualize yourself
the input sequence s sort of nodes and
so this this would be one layer we have
a five length sequence and we want to
transform it into the next length five
sequence and maybe it even helps to
label maybe like a B C D you can just
imagine kind of these of course as you
go up the layers it doesn't necessarily
always correspond to the same input
token but the position labeling them is
still it's pretty helpful I find
especially for you know lay things like
Bert or something like this so you want
to transform the sequence that's
incoming here into a another sequence
and the basic the basic mechanism in a
transformer if you go up the layers is
the routing of information so you want
to like route information around the
sequence and basically such that at the
end the whole sequence knows about every
word in the sentence knows about every
other word that there is in the sentence
knows about the associations between the
other words and so on such that you gain
sort of you start out with individual
words and at the end what you want is
sort of that every word has a pretty
good idea of what's going on with every
other word okay and that's why you
continuously as you
the lair route around this information
now the question is how do you route
this information how do you know which
word goes to which other word and here
maybe the sentence starts with the word
let's call Sara okay Sara and then it
goes on and some point it says she okay
so she is the pronoun and we can also
label these Sara she so if we want to if
we think how do how do we route
information it would be beneficial for
us
if the information that there is a word
Sara here in the sentence would be
routed to the word she because the word
she it's a pronoun it knows I am a
pronoun and if there is like a person in
the sentence that would be valuable
information for me like to know what's
kind of going on and to understand
myself better this clay every world
wants to understand itself and it kind
of calls out for information from the
other words in a transformer this is
done via what this paper calls this dot
product attention and that's the follows
every word every token emits what is
called a key and a value and the key and
the value are just two vectors so every
word is going to emit two vectors I'm
going to draw one at the bottom here and
I'm going to draw one at the top okay
like that so you can imagine the key as
sort of the word advertising what it is
two other words and the so these are the
keys down here and you sorry the top I
think I call it value that's wrong it's
called a query you can imagine the query
as a word asking describing what it
wants from others to know okay so in
that case you'll see that the vector
here and the vector here the these are
now routed by dot product so the ones
that align in the dot product in the
angle they will be routed to each other
so this would be routed here and maybe
you know okay I drew this this one will
be routed here and the others would be
kind of routed some a bit here and a bit
here maybe okay it gets it gets fuzzy
but you get the concept but in order to
do that you basically need the two poke
to put the dot product from every single
key with every value
sorry query and that gives you basically
this quadratic dot product that these
transformers have and that's expensive
okay so they have a little picture here
this is what a vanilla transformer does
every input here emits two things a
query and a key and then there is a dot
product attention to decide what's this
attention matrix okay now this attention
matrix is then used to aggregate these
values actually every token emits three
things also this value here which is
basically it's not that important but
this just describes the information that
you want to pass on to the next layer
and then it goes through this routing
right here that routes the information
to the correct output places and you get
your output now what they propose is
something different they propose this
dense synthesizer right here where
instead of the dot product attention
every single every single input here
emits a basically a row of this matrix
directly without having to go through
the dot product that helps a bit if you
imagine it in our little framework here
so let's draw this again and let's see
what this synthesizer by the way they
call this the dense synthesizer because
they have another variant as well okay
here's our here is our sequence the
lower layer we want to transform it in
the upper layer let's this is the sera
node and this is the XI node Sarah she
okay so how do we route information now
well okay I missed that in the dense
synthesizer framework every token just
gets to output basically it already gets
to output where it wants information
from so every single token here gets to
output where it wants information to
come from and by where because in the
original transformer the wear was
basically defined by these inner product
now the wear is just defined by the
position okay so it just says I want
information from position 2 & 3 or this
node here could say I want I want
information from position 5 and 3 okay
and this is dependent on which token
there is so each token looks at itself
and in the case here of XI you can
imagine this token says well I'm a
pronoun therefore I may be referring to
a person and I know that in the English
language a person is often at the
beginning of the sentence and therefore
I certainly want information from token
from position 0 it doesn't see that
there is this word sera here it simply
can see only the positions 0 1 2 3 4
okay so it will output it will basically
output each token here will output an L
dimensional vector and L here is the
length of the sequence an L dimensional
vector that already defines the
distribution of how you want the
information so I want lots of that and
then not much of that and maybe it wants
a bit of that and then not much of that
ok so each word up here is going to emit
this L dimensional vector ok so each
word each token decides for itself where
it wants information to come from paste
based purely on what the token it's a
yes okay and of course in the higher
layers this information like the
information of what the token is and
what else is there gets aggregated and
that's how computation happens but in a
fundamental level each node looks at
itself and decides where do I want
information from just given what I am
and not what others are so this results
in a in you not having to do this dot
product attention but of course you lose
the information of what's down here you
simply go on the positions of the nodes
and they they formalize this like this
so they basically say okay each each
transformer mechanism needs some sort of
a a softmax over this matrix B right
here which this is the this is this
routing matrix and then G of X is just
the values of X so G is often just a
linear function and they say well this B
here in the classic transformer is
computed via this dot product attention
can't we just simply have a function
right here that just outputs the be
given an X so we end it you see here X I
refers to one row so X here is an L by D
matrix and they say the sequence length
is L so if you imagine this if you this
is the sequence length X every X I is s
is a vector here of dimension D right
sort of like a word embedding okay now
what you want to do is you want to take
each individually run it through the
function f and then get out an L
dimensional vector sorry an L
dimensional vector this is of - an L and
if you do this with enough of the with
all of the X's you'll get an L by L
matrix which basically is now your
routing matrix it tells you so this
speed this thing
you that this particular piece in the
input sequence wants how much
information from this particular piece
in the output sequence or vice versa I
see this is the problem here they don't
really specify this be how this B matrix
will be composed from the in from the bi
that is bi a column or a row of this B
matrix I don't know and therefore it
could actually be the other way around
that the information it is not the sort
of the tokens deciding where they want
information from but it could be the
tokens deciding where they want to send
information to but just from the
notation I can sort of guess that it's
the way that I describe right here but I
hope you see the difference here right
before we had this dot product in it and
here each of these columns basically is
an independent evaluation of this
function that only considers X I and
doesn't consider any of the XJ that it
wants information from it simply goes by
position and they use for this they use
this basically this two layer one hidden
layer neural network right here two
weight matrices and a non-linearity
array Lu non-linearity so they replace
the dot product by simply learning what
the attention pattern is going to be per
individual token okay now they do it one
step further
they say okay so we've already lost the
dependency basically on what the on what
the input sequence tokens here are can
we also just kind of lose the dependency
of what the output token sequences here
are so what they propose in their second
variant this random synthesizer is the
following
is hey why don't we just learn how the
information is going to be routed
irrespective of which tokens come in
right we just we're just going to
this and it's going to be one routing
pattern for all of the possible input
output sequences that's it's just going
to be this routing pattern so they have
actually two variants first one where it
is really just random like they just
leave it random and they don't even
train it and the second one where they
train this thing but these things now
have nothing to do with the tokens
they're just fixed and they are just
global so this this would here be this
would directly be you learn this L by L
matrix and yeah so if this strikes you
bit in an odd way because you kind of
lose the dependence here their data in
this routing pattern and it's not really
routing anymore right and if you think
that you've seen this before somewhere
and you think hey that looks like a
feed-forward layer from from like your
very first MLP then you would be
absolutely correct and I'm not sure why
they don't point this out if I'm like I
have a really hard time believing that
they themselves trick them into such a
thing right here and so I can actually
actually show it right so that the
question is how is how is this here this
dense synthesizer how is this still is
this still different or the same as a
feed-forward layer and is this different
or the same as a feed-forward layer so
if you do the the math say and you look
at what a feed-forward layer is and a
feed-forward layer why I write my I of
entry in the output is going to be a sum
over all the inputs XJ multiplied by a
weight IJ okay so if whenever I can
represent something in this fashion
where I have a sum and then I have like
a fixed weight and that I learn and that
has nothing to do with X that is not
dependent on X
multiplied by X then it is a
feed-forward later basically or like a
fancy feed-forward later so let's look
at the dense synthesizer what does the
dense synthesizer do the dense
synthesizer says why I is equal to a sum
okay we're starting off we're starting
off well and so it says G of XJ of right
but this G usually is just a a weight
matrix where we compute the values right
we said this was the values of X so G is
usually just a matrix let's call it V W
V and then here we have like some soft
max thing right we have some soft Max
and the soft max is going to be over
this dense pattern right here that we
described sorry here and this pattern is
going to be f of X J right so no X I f
of X I is that correct
X I and here is a J maybe yes that's
correct
and F okay it's like - it's it's two
layers but we can basically say it's
like a weight matrix because ultimately
if we learn a neural network or a single
layer it it doesn't really matter to the
discussion here so let's call this air W
be X I so you see right here we do have
a weighted sum over the X J's but the
weight that the weighted sum is using is
dependent on X I right here and
therefore you can't you can't represent
this as just a feed-forward layer right
here of course if you have the full dot
product attention
then in here would actually be a dot
product between XJ and X I write so XJ
transpose X I or something like this so
what about what about this random
synthesizer so the random synthesizer
has why I has a weighted sum over this
WV x I that's the values softmax
over this matrix r and r is simply this
L by L matrix right here now you can
immediately see that this part right
here is static it doesn't depend on any
X and it is learned as in as a joint
function right so this if I just call
this w W IJ then I'm back to my
formulation right I'm I'm ham sorry
i J then I basically have my feet
forward later so the random synthesizer
is just a fancy way of writing a feat
for Lin I of course if he's going to
have the softmax you maybe have such
different inductive biases in learning
it but ultimately it is a is is a
straightforward feed-forward layer at
least that's what it looks like to me I
am very open to be convinced otherwise
okay so they have this drawing right
here on the left you see the vanilla
transformer the dense synthesizer in the
middle where you kind of learned how to
produce this matrix and then route the
value through it and on the right where
you simply output this in a learned or
actually completely random fashion and
then route your values through that to
the output okay now the question of
course is okay they also do factorize it
but this is not really the this is more
of a point where now you can actually if
you have such a matrix or you produce
such a matrix you can then factorize it
into sort of
lower dimensional matrices and that is
first of all to save space and it is
also a regularizer because what you're
essentially saying is you're applying an
inductive prior to say I I think these
matrices have like some low-level
structure to them and if you factorize
them that would that's a prior on that
exactly so you can factorize the dense
and the random synthesizer into smaller
matrices and that will save you
parameters and you can actually also mix
two so you can for example mix the
random and the dense synthesizer now you
have to pay attention it's not like an
interpolation if you mix random and
dense you will have to learn the
parameters of the random end of the
dense synthesizer so that's going to be
like strictly more powerful than either
one alone they list everything here
where they say the standard dot product
attention what we have is we have this
formula right here you can actually
formulate it in their framework you
condition on all the XJ for any X I and
and ah see here I wrote this as XJ I was
dumb it should be the entire X and there
is interaction between the tokens and
it's going to cost you two d squared
parameters now parameters is different
from computation which if you don't if
you don't do the dot product you also
save a bunch of computation but here
they look at a number of parameters so
in this random synthesizer you simply
have to put this matrix or its global it
there's no interaction and you are you
are it cost you l squared memory in l
squared parameters now often in these
models L and D are actually pretty
similar so L might be something like 512
tokens the length and the dimension
right here might also be something like
512 so first
say this is not really a saving in
parameters only when you go to the to
the factorized models right here can you
bring in this k and k is this lower
dimensional factorization and if K is
much much smaller than L then you save a
bunch of parameters the dense
synthesizer is formula is like this this
is how you produce the attention matrix
you condition on X i but not XJ right
for each Y I you condition on X I and
you do not care about the X J's there is
a it is local that means it depends on X
I so the the routing actually depends on
the information that goes through but
there is no interaction and your going
into d squared plus DL which is also
pretty much these two d squared and or
you go to this lower lower number here
if you choose a good K all right now
experiments so they apply this and we
are absolutely stoked how this is going
to turn out so they go on machine
translation now okay before before we go
into the results do you think machine
translation is a good or a bad task for
this model okay I think it is a good
task for this model is a very favorable
task for this model why why is machine
translation a favourable task well
mostly in machine translation if you
think about how information is routed so
I have I have a I have a sequence of
German let's call it or English let's
call it the dog barks and I have a
sequence of German they're honed belt
come on honed belt
now okay first of all I know they are
only talking about self attention so
this example here actually makes little
sense in the actual practical
applications but I just want to
demonstrate why machine translation
specifically has so how would you route
information here if you have to route
information between the two things what
you would do is pretty deterministically
do this right so in machine translation
what is very very very often the case is
that mostly you're going to align the
positions in the same way independent of
the input specifically here you would
always most of the time align the
beginning with the beginning the end
with the end and so on because for most
languages especially similar languages
like English and German the order of
sentences and number of words per thing
you need to express is going to be
roughly the same so if you did not know
about even about what the sequences were
or you only knew one of them like you
only knew there and you have to guess
where should information come from well
I know in English you also start with
like this what's this called an article
yeah
yes this is an article showing my
linguistic skills here you would also
you would also start with that right you
would say I want most information from
position 0 obviously I don't care what
their what what is their so I and again
I know they'd only do it in self
attention so it actually makes no sense
that I have two different languages here
but machine translation is probably a
task that lends itself very much to sort
of global globally learned or only
partial the partial observably learned
attention patterns because just because
of the nature of the task right so let's
keep that in mind and go to the go to
the results right here that they first
of all what they do is they list the
original transformer paper and
I have it here because they have to they
have this same experiment now this is
the kind of transformer we're talking
about right here and it is notable that
this paper only proposes to replace the
self attention that means the attention
that would be within one of these two
columns and not the attention that goes
across from the left to the right right
but still you can see that the attention
that goes from the left to the right
then in the next layer is going to end
up as self attention information right
so my I think my argument still counts
in the in this case in the machine
translation case alright so they have
this same experiment right here here yes
they have English German translation and
they their base model gets 27.3 and
that's what they evaluate right here
they list this 27.3 but they also say
when we train it we get a bit of a
higher number twenty seven point six
seven and especially on english french
they get a higher number than that but
let's stick to English German for now
now they also do language modeling which
the original paper didn't do and record
the perplexity right here okay so the
first thing they point out is if we
train the synthesizer with a fixed
random matrix that means we just put a
random routing and we do not we do not
ever change it what's there to learn so
if you want to learn something in the
transformer there are still many things
to learn there's the feed-forward nee
layers right there is the value encoder
and so on so it is it is reasonable to
assume that the transformer could sort
of learn to just handle the attendee
routing pattern that is in place and
that did the rest of the model can sort
of absorb that shock and interestingly
you get onto 23.9 so almost
twenty-four blow points and I mean it
seems they point out that it's fairly
close if you look here this 24 is
actually pretty far away it's the worst
the worst baseline right here in the
original paper this bite net had this 24
blue I mean it's I guess it's cool to
point out that it works
as such but you know in these tasks
actually many things work right with
with if you distill this down to some
sort of a bag of words model and so on
pretty sure you can get pretty pretty
good results as well and you can get you
know fairly you can go to 24 blue
actually I have no clue of this field
but I just want to point out just
because the number is in the same
ballpark doesn't mean that it is very
astonishing it's maybe just you have so
many parameters that the rest of the
model can sort of absorb this the shock
of not of not being able to learn this
and you can just handle whatever pattern
you put there it can just kind of work
with it
okay that's many people have observed if
you like put just random junk in the
lower layers of a CNN like random
filters never train them you can still
the rest of the network can adapt so
that's basically this effect right here
I don't think it's a testament to we
don't need the dot product attention
it's more like this this just happens in
deep learning then however they say if
we now learn this one matrix so we learn
this routing but globally we get into
twenty seven point two seven blue and
this already seems fairly close right
and you mainly need to compare with this
number right here because that's
actually the same training run and so on
so but still it is quite it is quite a
bit away it's point four blue points
away and that is a sort of significant
difference I think then they go further
if they
go to the dense synthesizer you can see
right here the model size is lower than
this one and they get twenty seven point
four three now they get even closer
right and they are actually on par if
they mix random and dense right here and
you can see that it's also almost the
same amount of parameters and when they
mix these random and vanilla so what
they now have is the dot product
attention plus a purely global
feed-forward it's sort of like a bias of
what you are out where then they can
out-compete this original model but also
now they have more parameters right so
this model you would expect it to be you
know strictly better than either of the
two alone and it is and it is actually
astounding that the synthesizer that
mixes the vanilla with the dense even
though it has even more parameters it
does worse so with these sort of results
especially then you go fiddle with like
point one you know between this and that
I know I said point four blow is a lot
so point one must be something and it
surely is but also it's always the
question of how many hyper parameter
tunings you put into something like this
and generally you you should always sort
of look at this if you were a research
and had to put the best possible numbers
here what would you do and then you
correct for that in your mind for how
much it might actually work
if you if you were to if you were to you
know go ahead and and train that on your
data but nevertheless it it gives some
cool insights right and what I'm a bit
confused by is that if you sort of look
at the original paper and you look at
the perplexities and they have a table
down here where they compare a bunch of
they're in
stanchions of their model and you
compare the comparison the perplexity on
a language modeling task and the
perplexity here seems to correlate
extremely well with the blur score right
whereas the perplexity here if you look
at the perplexities over here they do
correlate but I somehow I have the
feeling they don't really correlate as
much here which sort of speaks to the
fact that you're gonna see in the rest
of the paper that these models they tend
to sometimes be able to do well but then
other times not and it's not really
clear super clear when so look at this
for example they now apply their models
to summarization and dialogue generation
right these are two tasks wherein each
output text and you can see that the
results are all over the place
so in this metric Rouge two and Rouge is
sort of an Engram overlap metric between
gold standards and what you produce in
this metric the original transformer is
best but in Rouge one this synthesizer
mixed here is the best and in Rouge ell
this one is the best and in dialogue
generation all of them are actually not
as good as this one right here where
it's just the dense which is strictly
less powerful than the ones on the
bottom but so as you as you can see yeah
I think what you should take away from
this is it it is interesting that it
sometimes works but it seems to be a
fair bit of shakiness to these to these
results okay now they go on and they
test this on super glue and this is a
benchmark so glue and super glue they
consist of these different tasks right
here and now we are out of the text
generation game we are in the game of
for example you have two sentences and
you need to decide which which one is
like which one entails the other or are
they contradictory or things like this
so it's more of a like say a
classification task and people
apply different models so it's no longer
a text generation task so they switch
model instead of the vanilla transformer
from the attention is all you need paper
they now go on to the t5d text to text
transformer and they change they simply
take the architecture and they change
the attention in there with their
attention and you can see right here
that the results are quite different
than before
so in every single case either the t5
model the base model with the dot
product attention is the best model or
the synthesizer but including V so plus
V means plus vanilla means it also has
the dot product attention plus this
learned thing right here okay so R is
now they learned I think the learned
right I would be surprised if it was the
random random but it could also be but
in any case it's strictly better right
it's strictly more powerful model and
the only way can actually perform worse
is when you know it's too many
parameters and so on and they kind of
take stuff from each other and there is
effects where more parameters can hurt
you but never is any model that doesn't
have the dot product attention on on top
and these authors here argue that thus
this can be largely attributed to the
fact that the encode or self attention
in the t5 setting also functions as a
cross sentence attention so what do they
mean here if in the t5 is just as I
understand it this is just like an
encoder like Bert
so imagine imagine maybe this is Bert
right what Bert is simply an encoder
only transformer that means you here you
put in your sequence and out again comes
a sequence and you have like a special
token that you use for classification
and so on so this is less when you have
to generate text but more when you want
to classify text or
like this find something in a text and
what you would do if you have two
sentences you need to decide something
about them you put the first sentence
here and then you say it put like a
separator token here this is usually
called like a separator token and then
you put the second sentence here is you
can just concatenate them and you let
them go into the transformer and they
argue that if you do self attention on
this entire sequence then you get
attention patterns like this and this is
sort of like chorus attention between
sequences right it's not really self
attention and that's why their method
doesn't work because it basically deals
with self attention but I'm not really
buying that argument I mean if this is a
sequence it is if this is one sequence
this is a self attention and if you were
going to argue that out of the blue a a
token in your case like in your original
formulation can simply you know just by
looking at itself know where where which
position it wants the information from
then certainly here this token could
also learn that it wants information
from over here or from the first word
here I don't I don't really see the
difference maybe maybe you need to
somehow standardize where this separator
token is so that it's always in the same
place and that the second sentence
always starts at the same place but if
you have that then I really don't see
any difference in the argument you can
make here that this shouldn't work as
much as the others what I think is
happening is that this task is simply
involves more difficult reasoning
involves more routing of information
like dynamic routing that's actually
dependent on what's in the tasks rather
than something like machine translation
which most of the time has some global
routing bias like like some some pattern
that works pretty well across all
alright so the last part here is where
they kind of introspect the model and in
the in the first thing they say okay we
look at the distribution of weights
so these are the weights the way it's in
the decoder at the beginning of training
and you can already see that the
standard transformer weights are and the
synthesizer weights are different from
the sorry the dense synthesizer weights
are different from the random
synthesizer weights and this probably is
mostly due to the fact of how you
initialize like these deep learning
frameworks if you have a matrix they
will look at what's this dimension
what's this dimension and will calculate
how they have to initialize it such that
sort of the the total norm of a random
vector that goes through stays the same
sorry the vector would go through like
it would go in here and out there so you
see if it changes dimension then if you
just randomly initialize with all the
same like every matrix with the same
number then like with a normal
distribution then the in this case the
vector would gain in norm and to account
for that you initialize the matrices
such that the vector norms approximately
stay the same and this is why they're I
guess why there are different
initializations here and you can see
this at the end of the training now
these in different layers right here
it's pretty much always the same pattern
now they they say they just remark it so
this this is what I find weird they just
say what the graphs show they don't
interpret it like I would expect
something like oh this pattern is
exactly what we would expect from our
model because something something
something right like if they claim that
this attention is being able to be
learned and I just don't see why they do
this stuff they simply point out oh yeah
this this is higher here and this is
higher here but I don't even see that as
too interesting given that is this is
how you initialize it a like if you are
shift everything to the left of it and
you know this is wall so it's like this
piles up here then this is exactly how
it turns out I don't I don't see you
know what what this is
I mean especially since they don't make
any claim of what it is supposed to mean
and the same here they say the effect of
the number of heads okay we we
investigate the effect and the number of
heads on the random synthesizer models
you know and they train the number of
heads now somewhere in the text they say
I remember they say since you know since
we don't dynamically route it is very
important for our models very crucial to
have many attention heads right such
that basically you don't have one
routing pattern you have many routing
patterns that you learn globally so they
say it's very important for our model to
have many attention heads and that guess
that's what they're trying to
demonstrate here but again they simply
say what's happening they don't
interpret it and and they don't compare
it to anything that just you know put it
here they just put the number and I
don't like is this good is this is this
bad can you compare it to something and
also here in the so here in the original
paper they do the same thing here as you
can see the number H is the heads and
they do oblate this but at the same time
they adjust the dimensions of the key
and value vector such that in total they
have the same amount of parameters right
so they can really investigate it is one
big attention head better or worse than
many small attention has is there a
trade off and they find here that there
is a bit of a trade off like there is a
sweet spot you don't want too many you
know one too much because they get too
small something like this but first we
like we don't know whether or not have
they simply changed the heads but left
every other parameter the same or have
they also adjusted the dimensions
because if they haven't adjusted the
dimensions then this this increase would
be absolutely expected because you now
have more parameters and if they have
adjusted then can we compare this to you
know something because this here is the
this is the t5 small this is not the
original transformer like is this
big is this small and what does it say
about the claim that you made that the
number of heads is so important for your
model can you validate this using this
so it's just a bit of like this entire
page here it's just they just measure
some things and then they state them
here and and you you're somehow supposed
to guess what they mean by stating that
here okay but that was enough for me
ranting so they give some supplementary
material right here but in essence what
I like about the paper is sort of the
thinking that goes into this thinking
outside the box asking the fundamental
questions about these models do we
really need this what what do they do I
don't think it's super well investigated
really from a scientific point like the
other thing the formulation of
hypotheses it simply trains these things
and then makes some claims but the
claims interact you know with the number
of parameters here and so on so and
they're sort of noisy all around and of
course the fact that this thing here
turns out to be a fully connected layer
in disguise is also pretty funny but I
get it it's a fan it's like it's it's
more it's not exactly the same thing but
it you know yeah alright so that was my
take on this paper if you have a
different one let me know in the
comments for sure I read all of them and
at least I try and I've always succeeded
so far alright I'll see you next time
bye bye